is wayne newton week here at good day
and i was honored to be able to sit down
with mr las vegas himself we chatted
about his new show at the flamingo and
really what it's like playing in such an
intimate setting for the first time and
i have a hint
he loves it
the other night we had a wonderful
there was a lady that came in i i don't
know how much she had to drink but uh
she's still up about a third of the way
to the show and said i have wanted to
see you for the last 30 years and i get
here and now my phone is dead and can i
plug it in
and she gets up from her seat
and walks over pulls one of
the wires on stage and plugs in her
phone
and i said wow anybody else need
anything
for you how fun that you can kind of
poke a little fun with it because it is
so small
yes it is and it uh it gives me a chance
to
read the audience that i don't usually
get a chance to do
i start my shows out no matter which
one i'm doing
uh
with three different kind of songs
up tempo first
big band second and a ballot third and
that kind of tells me from the audience
reaction
where that group is in terms of their
appreciation of what they want to hear
and they know that
if they have a
favorite song or
a favorite story
that they can yell out on this kind of
intimacy
and
uh and we'll do what is
whatever it is they want to hear
yeah isn't that fun he said he can read
the room now and because his band and he
have been together for so long they can
just kind of look at each other he could
tell them the song name it and
there it is no show is ever the same